The three best free add-ons that you can download to
your browser can let you record the camera
at the same time and record the screen. You can use
this video and upload it to YouTube, or you can also share it
with your colleagues at work when you want to
explain something to them, as they say. The video
is 1000 words long instead of sending emails and writing them
with  People can summarize the topic in a video that you
record and send to him directly. At the end of this video, I will
tell you in a way how, if you work
in a sales place, you can use the topic of explaining
this video, so if you have Samar, send him
the video.
Peace be upon you, Omar Mohsen. I will not tell you that
I miss you because you know.  If you miss me
so much, I miss talking to you so much. We miss
making videos. God willing, may God bless
the time. We will come back to you again. I mean, let's stay
in the topic and talk about additions.
Today, all the links. The additions will be
present in the video description, so you can click on them
and open the link directly. I'm talking about the addition.
Number three, which is the add-on, is called
a video. How do you access it? The first thing you will
go to is the video. Let’s go back to the screen, and this is the screenshot that I am talking to you about. You will
see the script
for the video. You will click on the money and it will reach you.
But if a subscript appears, then I certainly don’t need to
tell you the subscript if you are expecting the video.  It will be
fine.
We will talk about it. We will start with the first add-on called the one
we made together. Confirm the conditions and enter
with them. I want to ask you a question in what field so that he
knows why it
remains available with us.
It is directly yours. Therefore, you do not
need a device with very high specifications to capture the
screen. We will continue together and press on.  Girl and Action, so we
go here and click on the add so that it appears on
the side above. After that, we
record the first video using. We click on
Record from the video. As you can see, its screen is simple. Turn on the camera or just screenshot or camera only and
it starts at 30 minutes for one video.
Now I am recording the screen.  At any time,
if I want something, I write it, and this is a beautiful, honesty feature, and you
edit it or produce a light product. Of course, you
can download your video to your device to upload it
to social media, or you can create it
here. You can remove, for example, an intro. If there is anything in it, you can
listen to the video that you are making, and so on, and press
on
Anyone who opens the link like this will be able to watch
your video in this way
[music].
Or you can download it and upload it to YouTube
or any social media platform. This is the
main interface of the program:
YouTube, Facebook, Facebook.
Number two is Screen Cast 5. Click on the second
link. The second link will be delivered to you.  Directly
to the Google store, click on Chrome to
add the above to Oxygen. Immediately after we finish
the addition, we will go to above and click on PIN
so that the above appears for us, and we click on it from here to
log in using our email. It is preferable,
of course, to have your email so that the
videos that you use will be saved.  I imagine her, we
press on the lighter, we press on Run and Nix. He
asks you a few questions to find out what. Mattak keeps telling you to press on. He told her and don’t forget to turn on the
camera and microphone. This is the
interface of the program. We don’t care about anything. We will
go up and stay on the extension and click
on the add and notice that he is asking me
similar questions.  The first addition is that I want pictures of the tab that
you are opening only, not the entire desktop or
the camera. Just choose the microphone that you
are using and do you want to
show the
camera or not? I will show it. We click on Record and we start along. We will notice what is under the edge of the tab that has the camera,
and here it asks me if I want a specific window of the things.
Whoever has it open or the Internet, the whole screen. I
want its pictures to be
very beautiful. We will notice here that there are
different things in the mouse. The click pen appears so that
you can start drawing. If you want to make squares, for example, explaining the things you are explaining, you can make a boss. Of course, the
video is also completely hidden, so that whoever
watches you after that.  Finish at length, press Stop, and
after it finishes, this interface will open for you.
The first thing you should not forget to do is call it
a video so that it does not get lost in the middle of the videos.
After that, it indicates a length that cuts, for example, something from
the beginning or from the end. Okay.
We will notice that
this link remains possible. The first thing you press is
You can send the link to anyone directly, and you can
also export the video by downloading it to
YouTube or to your device, or as a GIF,
or uploading it directly to Google Drive. Also, there is a nice animation
in this add-on. If you
can, make the question inside me a video via
InterActives as follows.  Do you see this? In this
place, we click on Atwitcher, enter the question and what is the
correct answer in it, and you click on Save
and Save in the minute that you chose, and
you will see how many people answered here and your answers.
Who are the names of the people who answered? The
next step is the video analysis. They have
very strong editing. The video is
on  Your browser can hide some things and
block them, for example certain texts. You can create a
video group and cut out specific places from it. Fouad
Media can only hide videos. You can
zoom in on a specific area in the video. You can put it on and it goes and comes back. After I finish doing
video sports, I can put it on
Google Drive directly.
Number three
[music]
Add a color. We click on it. It is a boy. It opens with us. It opens. Of
course, permission is required in order to record the use of the
camera and microphone. I will do it. Say it from here. And that is how
we downloaded the add-on. We will start using the
add-on. We will choose from here Square and Cameroon. The
entire screen. Or we can open a specific tab.
Here we will try to confirm.  My sound is working and this is
good.
For example,
this is initial and there is still a nice feature.
Of course, you can change the beginning or background. You can choose a ready-made template, and this is something else that looks
nice like this. This is the intro for the
video. Don’t forget to subscribe to the channel. We are ready.
Let’s start connecting the
video. We will start it here. Ask me if I want pictures.
Press Share like this on the entire screen. It will start
filming all of my screen with this video. There is a
very nice feature, which is the Fluor Content feature,
so that you can hide text, a video, or a
specific thing. It is
not good. It will
stop recording the video and
continue recording your video. We have finished recording the
video. Everything is fine. We will press on.  On Stop
in order to stop this. I finished the video. We will notice that
this is my video. The first three seconds
are a GIF or animated video.
We will notice the first thing that there is a question here that I ask
you. It will come to you on your browser when someone watches the video.
If we press “Law,” anyone will open the video.
You will receive a notification on the browser, and not only that,
if you also receive an email that someone has watched
the video now, if you also want this feature,
it will still be available, and of course they have a mobile application that you
can download from above
this video with anyone. If there are emails, you can put them
or you can get the email at all times.  The link and send him anything. Let's
try this. We open the link and see how it
works.
Of course, the speed of the video can leave
only one person. From here, he can add an emoji in the same
place he sees the need. After the
emoji, he asks me for my name
so that it is recorded in the data base. You see every time I
click.  I have an emoji that records at a certain time,
and of course I can make a comment on the video. Thank
you.
And the name, of course. All of this is revealed in the minute or
two in which you wrote the comment. And not
only that, you can be a viewer to record a video of the person
who made the video, as you can see under the comments
display method, which is very powerful.  As for
people, I can delete my comment. Ok, let us
go back to editing again, and we will notice that the first thing in the
translation review means that you can write
texts that say the words you said in Arabic
or in English,
or put on the video as you want. You can
stop from here,
whatever you are saying.  He has a soul to a specific place. Where is
this? Possible link on YouTube? Possible
Excel sheet link? Here, for example, I am speaking on the
Norwegian channel, and we can play a
video. I want in this place to have a button in my video that I click on that will take me to a specific place,
and this, of course, you cannot do on social
media.  Not even on YouTube, it remains below in the
comments. I mean, click on each action and I will put the link
here as you can see.
We are now open to the live broadcast that contains
the videos. How many people have commented?
How many people have made an action ray as
you can see? The lighting is very awesome and the
other additions. I mean, experiment. I tried.  There are three of them, and each
one has a use, and I have a use for it. Tell me
which addition you liked the most in the comments below. We will go into the
last part about which we
mentioned the video. How can a video like this increase your sales? And I will tell you from a personal experience that happened to me. I entered into one of the companies that was trying to talk to me because  She sells me one of
the services. I found a video of someone coming to me. She does it for me,
bye bye. She holds a piece of paper like this and writes for me on
it. My name will be done to me like this. The first three seconds
of the GIF or animation, I will build the
animation. Of course, I thought of this video for a reason. I
checked the name of the site. I blamed it and said, “No, that’s it.”  A
normal video, and I watched the video until the end, and I still prefer it until
now. I remember that this could have been two or
three hours long. This method is very powerful. It can
help you in preparing content that will be brief and
tell you what service you want to provide and how it
can affect the company to which you are
selling the product or service.  Yours
and the site here is a video, I hope it offers a direction. You
can use it, and I have a simbol. What I said
a while ago has a discount called Templet. From here, you
see, you saw the
video, but I will see you well in a new video.
Peace be upon you.